I hope do hereby declare that justy
greening is duly elected to serve as MP
for coming thank you very much mr. mayor
I'm delighted to have been reelected as
the Member of Parliament for Putney were
happy no Southfields this has been an
election very much fought in the shadow
of terrorism including here in London
but in every single community there have
been votes cast for different parties
but they've all had one thing in common
and that is that every single vote cast
in this election has been a vote against
those who want to threaten our way of
life and for all of us who believe in
our democracy that's something that's
hugely important two years ago when I
was elected I talked about how much
opportunity and social mobility meant
for me something that I know from my own
personal experience has been first
person in my family to go to university
in fact when I got involved in politics
no one in my family had ever been
involved in politics before and it was
something completely new for all of us
but I got involved not because I had a
big life mission to become an MP because
I wanted to make a difference I wanted
to make a difference in my local
community that I'm proud to be part of
and I wanted to make a difference for my
country and that's why I feel that
running for Parliament being part of a
democracy becoming a member of
parliament is one of the greatest
privileges that anyone can have bestowed
on them in a lot of their lives I
finally like to say a huge thank you to
my local community I've been out on the
doorstep and the support life has has
been fantastic not just during this
election
over the last 12 years as a local MP
I've loved absolutely every single
minute of it it's a privilege to be able
to continue to represent a community a
massive thank you to all of the
community came out support from it to
support me who came out to campaign for
me I will be back out tomorrow doing my
level best to make sure I keep
representing us and once again thank you
so much for your support it's privileged
to be the Member of Parliament thank you
[Applause]